Hong Kong es uno de esos lugares que no necesitan
ser presentados, ¿Quién no lo conoce?
Todo el mundo lo conoce. Situado en el sur de
China, hablamos de una ciudad viva, agitada,
en permanente movimiento,
pero, sobre todo, hablamos de una ciudad de
grandes contrastes.
En Hong Kong no te puede sorprender ver camiones
ruinosos junto a coches de altísima gama;
edificios prácticamente en ruina pegados,
literalmente, a lujosos rascacielos; o restaurantes
de muchísimos tenedores frente a puestos
de comida…como de decirlo… con dudosas
garantías higiénicas.
Eso sí, hay un elemento común denominador:
en Hong Kong todos los huecos son pequeños,
no importa si hablamos de un carísimo centro
comercial o de una improvisada tienda tradicional,
en Hong Kong cada metro está híper-aprovechado.
De todas formas, fueron dos cosas las que más me
llamaron la atención la primera vez que pise
Hong Kong: primero, los rascacielos que se
construyen con andamios de bambú, que sí,
son muy resistentes, pero impresionan.
Y lo segundo, la enorme densidad de gente que hay en muchas
zonas de la ciudad. Amigos, un consejo antes de seguir,
si no te gustan las grandes concentraciones
de gente, olvídala, esta ciudad no es para
ti... Pero no nos desviemos.
Hong Kong ha sido, claramente, uno de los
grandes milagros económicos del S. XX.
De hecho, fue el modelo tomado como ejemplo por
el mismísimo Milton Friedman para mostrar
sus tesis en favor del libre mercado.
-"Si usted quiere ver realmente como el mercado libre trabaja, debe venir a este lugar".
Fijaros, tras la segunda Guerra mundial,
Hong Kong era una ciudad de apenas unos 600.000 habitantes
y un ingreso equivalente a una cuarta parte
del de Reino Unido, 60 años más tarde la
población supera los 7 millones de personas,
y el ingreso per cápita se ha prácticamente
igualado al británico.
Si, además, tenemos en cuenta los diferentes
niveles de precios, su PIB per cápita resulta
muy superior al de Reino Unido.
Durante todo ese tiempo Hong Kong no solo
se ha convertido en el cuarto mayor centro
financiero del mundo y en una de las diez
plazas comerciales más importantes, sino
que además, yo diría sobre todo, ha sido un refugio para millones
de chinos que escaparon de la pobreza y la
violencia de la China de Mao.
En toda esta evolución ha tenido mucho que
ver el amplio ecosistema de libertad económica
que se respira en la ciudad.
No hablamos, desde luego, de un paraíso libertario,
pero a día de hoy Hong Kong es, considerada
como la economía más libre del mundo y la
cuarta donde más fácil resulta hacer negocios.
En cualquier caso, sobre las claves de su
desarrollo económico ya hablaremos en otro
vídeo, hoy nos vamos a centrar en la vertiente
política y en las amenazas que se ciernen
sobre su estructura institucional y que puede,
incluso, poner en riesgo este progreso.
Y para ello tenemos, necesariamente, que empezar
la gran paradoja a la que se enfrenta Hong
Kong casi como seña de identidad. Me explico,
Hong Kong es China, pero una China libre,
o al menos más libre.
UN PAÍS, DOS SISTEMAS
Hong Kong fue una colonia británica hasta
1997 cuando la ciudad volvió a integrarse
en China, algo que no ocurría desde el s.XIX.
Bien, China era y es hoy en día una dictadura
donde el respeto a los derechos humanos y
a las libertades civiles brilla por su ausencia.
Esto obligó a los gobiernos de Londres y
Pekín a negociar una salida, porque evidentemente
ni los ciudadanos de Hong Kong estaban dispuestos
a perder sus derechos, ni Londres podía tolerar
que en esta ciudad se aplicase el autoritario
modelo chino… no al menos completamente.
Tras muchas negociaciones, en 1984 se llegó
al acuerdo conocido como la Declaración Conjunta
Chino-Británica, que establecía que durante
los siguientes 50 años desde el traspaso
de soberanía se aplicaría en Hong Kong un
modelo político distinto al de la China continental.
Así, Hong Kong, tras incorporarse a China
en 1997, pasó a ser una Región Administrativa
Especial donde rige la llamada Ley Básica
que les otorga a sus ciudadanos derechos y
libertades absolutamente inimaginables en
cualquier otro lugar del país a excepción
de Macao, que también se integró en China
con el mismo modelo:
Los ciudadanos de Hong Kong tienen reconocidas
las libertades de expresión, prensa, publicación,
reunión, asociación y manifestación. Tienen
acceso pleno a los medios de comunicación
internacionales y la censura virtual, la conocida
como cibermuralla, no se aplica.
Además, Hong Kong tiene su propia moneda,
su propia política de inmigración y aduanas,
su policía y sus tribunales propios.
Pues bien, en un primer momento las cosas
discurrieron francamente bien: el crecimiento
económico acompañaba, los hongkoneses mantenían
su estatus de libertad, podían aplicar políticas
propias y, además, Hong Kong se convirtió
en la puerta natural para las inversiones
extranjeras en China.
Sin embargo, al cabo de unos pocos años comenzaron
a aparecer nubes negras en el horizonte.
LIMITACIONES DEMOCRÁTICAS
La Ley Básica reconoce derechos civiles,
pero no hace lo mismo con la Democracia.
De hecho, China tiene de facto, el control
del Parlamento y del poder ejecutivo ¿Cómo
lo hizo? Pues bien,
1. En el parlamento de Hong Kong solo la mitad
de los diputados se escogen mediante elección
universal, la otra mitad la escoge un grupo
cerrado formado en la práctica por empresarios
e instituciones afines a China.
2. El jefe ejecutivo, esto es el Presidente
del gobierno, se escoge por un comité de
1.200 personas vinculadas, de una forma u
otra, al Partido Comunista Chino.
3. Todos los cargos públicos deben jurar
su lealtad y su compromiso con China, de tal
forma que la puerta para considerar determinadas
posiciones políticas como ilegítimas está
abierta
4. La Ley Básica de autonomía de Hong Kong
queda subordinada a la Asamblea Popular China.
Ahora bien, el pacto entre China y Reino Unido
exigía que a partir de 2017 debería elegirse
por sufragio universal del Presidente del
Ejecutivo, y aquí es donde China comenzó
a faltar la palabra dada.
El ENGAÑO CHINO Y LAS MOVILIZACIONES SOCIALES.
El 31 de agosto de 2014 la Asamblea Nacional
de Pekín puso en marcha la reforma electoral
para elegir al jefe del gobierno de esta región
especial. Y aquí estaba la sorpresa:
Sí, Pekín reconocía el sufragio universal,
pero solo se podría elegir entre dos o tres
candidatos escogidos previamente por el Partido
Comunista Chino JA ¡Democracia popular lo
llaman!
A los pocos días comenzaron las movilizaciones
civiles, lideradas en un primer momento por
estudiantes, algunos de apenas 17 años.
Claro, como explicarle a un joven libre, formado
y con pleno acceso a internet y a los medios
de comunicación de todo el mundo, que a pesar
de todo debe resignarse a estar sometido a
la dictadura china.
La reacción de las autoridades a las primeras
huelgas y movilizaciones no fue del todo amable:
decidieron utilizar la mano dura y la represión
policial.
Pero el resultado, la verdad, fue el contrario
al que imaginaban, Movidos por el miedo a
quedar sometidos a Pekín y por la solidaridad
con los estudiantes detenidos, cada vez más
gente se lanzó a la calle.
Pronto, una gran movilización ciudadana ocupó
el centro de Hong Kong, bajo el liderazgo
de las plataformas Occupy Central y Scholarism.
La represión policial recurrió al lanzamiento
de gas lacrimógeno y gas pimienta, y la población
respondió, junto al empleo de toallas y mascarillas,
abriendo sus paraguas para mitigar el efecto
de los gases. Así se fraguó el nombre por
el que ya se conoce este movimiento: la revolución
de los paraguas.
La ocupación del centro duró 79 días, y
desde entonces la conflictividad ha continuado
con brotes esporádicos y jóvenes cada vez
más escorados, no solo hacia la exigencia
de democracia, sino también hacía tesis
independentistas. Algo que por cierto China
ya ha dicho no va a tolerar bajo ningún concepto,
aunque tenga que hacer uso de la bota militar.
Por cierto, hace poco China llegó a secuestrar
a 5 libreros de Hong Kong por difundir ideas
contra el control de la metrópoli.
En este contexto, en septiembre de 2016 se
celebraron elecciones y muchos de los líderes
de las protestas fueron elegidos como diputados.
Sin embargo, sus llamadas contra Pekín y
a favor de la independencia han vuelto a abrir
la caja de pandora. De momento dos diputados
han sido ya apartados de su cargo.
Ojo los derechos civiles solo están protegidos
hasta 2047 y la intromisión de China en los
asuntos de la región es cada vez mayor. Y
esto tiene un coste porque incrementa el riesgo
percibido por los inversores.
Es muy posible que esta sea una de las causas
que han propiciado que en los últimos años
el crecimiento de Singapur haya sido muy superior.
Bien ¿Tu qué opinas? ¿Deben los ciudadanos
hongkoneses luchar por su libertad? ¿Querrá
China terminar con la libertad en esta región?
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like, y
si aún no lo has hecho no te olvides de suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima!